[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to GameSpot's
III stage I'm Mike McCarty I'm here with
Lucy James II we are also here with Elle
from Creative Assembly hello you've been
showing off Total War three kingdoms a
little more I know there's the release
trailer a few weeks ago at this point
yeah that's right yeah miel trailer not
really so yeah yeah yeah yeah no yeah
but yeah what's over here a three we've
got a playable battle which is one of
the siege battles from the game yes so
we're really talking about you know it's
the first time we've we've shown off at
all so we're really talking about what
it's all about what how we're building
the game and what that period is all
about as well because it's totally
fascinating as a historical period yeah
it's a long-running franchise to say the
least and we are gonna jump right into a
live demo briefly or momentarily but I
do want to kind of for people watching
get the elevator pitch from you what is
total war three kingdoms is how is it
setting itself apart of cool so it's the
next big historical gangster of course
we've done fantasy games of the
Warhammer recently but it's the next
great historical game in the type of War
series and it's SETI nation China which
is a period we haven't tackled before
yeah and it's the beauty of it is it's
kind of it's not just a regular history
game because the obviously the kind of
first second third century AD in China
fascinating period of kind of civil war
and turmoil lots of tyranny and
revolutions and finally unification as
well it's a fascinating period and
totally perfect for a total war game but
we're taking elements from the romance
of the three kingdoms which was the kind
of historical epic novel of the period
actually written in the 14th century by
by Chinese writer and it takes the kind
of warlords and heroes and the governors
and the big you know the kind of key
characters of the period and they are
written larger than life in the romance
so we're taking a lot of kind of
inspiration from that and you know the
romance of the three kingdoms those
those stories are told and retold even
today in movies and comics and cartoons
so it's kind of its kind of a
fascinating period to deal with because
there's all these
kind of interpretations of these these
huge characters who you know like
warriors who slew 2,000 men in a single
battle single-handedly and you know all
the kind of crazy stuff that they got up
to and that's that's because we want to
bring an element of an to the game I
keep coming across the story about the
guy he get someone got shot in the eye
with an arrow and yeah yeah yeah
yeah guy got from them Yahoo done here
he was yes it was one of the great
Warlord's he was the general himself and
he was a it was a cousin of South Lao
who was one of the great the great major
leaders of the period this kind of
strategic masterminds and he was an ally
of his and yeah when it's a battle
against the forces of lubu which we'll
see in the demo today and lubu one of Lu
boos arches shot him in the eye with an
arrow so rather than falling dead as you
might expect if he was shot in the iron
arrow in in fury he pulls the arrow out
and and eats his own eyeball yeah and
then proceeds to slay the general of the
army who'd who'd shot him in the eye so
and then puts an eyepatch on and carries
on fighting as we all do in such
situation exactly you do your best with
it with a bad situation well well I'm
excited that we have a demo ready of
life yeah let's jump into it though good
and we got someone from Creative
Assembly back here as well ready to play
so tell us what you're showing us here
today so this is the battle of CRP this
is the city of CRP here and this is sow
sow sow sow is like the guy I mentioned
just now great general and he said this
this is this was the battle in history
where sau sau finally defeated lubu and
Lubell Ubu was this tremendous why he
was that he was the most powerful
warrior three kingdoms period you know
soon as I mentioned thousands of men
himself and and became rather notorious
he was very self-serving he was very
it's totally unscrupulous he he kept
like making alliances with warlords and
then killing them and then moving on and
sealing alliances with other people so
and by this point by the Battle of zrp
Looby was pretty much you know treated
as a betrayer by absolutely everyone
nobody trusted him so so this is the
battle where
Souths out who's expanding his territory
at this point his territory brushes up
against luby's stronghold city of zrp
and he sees an opportunity to take
newbie down for good so that's what this
battle is all about so what we're doing
is showing off some of the kind of units
they've got a warrior types that we've
got you know built around ancient china
and in short we've got an entire army
here performing a siege against this
city so so it's quite a varied Army's
else out there like sands satin the
field on his own and one of the one of
the nice new features is if you check
out the unit cards along the bottom
that's all the different units and the
army led by the different generals and
you know in in all our previous total
war games armies were led by a single
general right but now I mean there's so
many characters in this period and we
want to we want to play to that so we've
we've built armies around the idea of
retinues so you can have multiple
generals in an army each of whom brings
his own unique retinue of troops and
each of the generals has a different
kind of character class as it were so so
you age in the kind of central figure
and in the unit cards there he's a
guardian which is a very tanky character
he's kind of a blockade runner he can
you can throw him into melee against
hundreds of other regular units and
he'll just stand there and weather the
storm and he can you know lock stuff
down on the battlefield for you where's
there's all these other different unit
that sorry general types such as
strategists and Vanguard's and champions
then they will bring something different
to the party essentially gameplay wise
and they have all their their own sort
of strengths and weaknesses yeah so
flying over the city here and you could
see the detail were building into this
you know research has gone on into the
sort of buildings at the time and that's
lubu himself this is this mighty warrior
of the Three Kingdoms period this is the
great betrayer satyr top he's got this
epic mount basically this horse is
called head to head red hair very good
horse armor it's very good horse it's
the best voiceover yeah yeah
flamboyant and yeah it's so with with
these with these characters and and sort
of minor generals major delts wherever
they are if you just sit in the campaign
game if you defeat them in battle
there's a
so you can loop their items off them and
equip them onto your on the general so
right red hair there this particular
mount quite a prestigious creature
everybody new red hair is the fastest
horse in the Three Kingdoms period and
so if we defeated lubu there's a chance
we would be able to loot red hair and
then sticks out some on him and what an
insult that would be to do boo right so
so what if what would happen if one of
our generals got killed would we still
have access to the units that he brings
or do they all kind of know they they
they go with him they go with his army
so so the idea is when when you lose one
of your generals his his retinue will
route his retinue will run so so yeah I
mean you have you have an overall
commander for the army as well so
south-south is this in this in so you'll
see that he gets the big kind of aura
around him which is you know he's kind
of morale bonus and all the buffs that
he brings as a particular character type
so yeah we very tumultuous time a lot of
alliances a lot of backstab salute like
that has to play in what happens if our
generals don't get on what if they have
conflicting ideal ideologies so that is
that's really kind of the heart of how
Three Kingdoms is different from
previous total war games because we're
building the entire campaign game around
these characters they're the absolute
cornerstone of that of the whole
experience and in a way we've never done
before we've added tremendous depth to
characters in their personalities and
their drives they have a kind of they
have a kind of satisfaction level with
their place in the world they have a
list of friends and a list of rivals so
so as an example you could have two
characters in the same faction who
deeply deeply dislike each other and one
of them might dislike the other one so
much that he actually leaves your
faction Wow and goes and signs up with
one of your enemies it becomes a
governor or a general for that guy right
so so these guys have more agency of
their own right yeah
and also while while they'll you know as
they as they kind of grow and gain
experience and the sort of level up
throughout the course of a campaign
you'll discover more about their
personalities we have this kind of idea
of predestination so rather than simply
being a kind of tool where you just
point put points into a certain skill
tree and then that character is very
good at one thing these guys you'll
learn about their personalities and
their drives and their motivations and
and the kind of things they like as the
more time you spend with them in the
campaign game basically so and and
really the whole thing's built around
this there's a sort of core concepts in
Chinese culture called Guan XI which is
it's a it's a concept which which
embodies sort of interpersonal
relationships and your your place in the
network if you like and it has you know
embodies concepts of kind of reciprocity
and honorable conduct and you know and
that that's where this whole friendship
and rivalry thing comes in so you could
have two characters who are incredibly
good friends and an example is you might
have a governor and a general in an
enemy faction who had tremendously good
friends but the governor doesn't
particularly like his faction leader
because he's very warlike right so his
faction satisfaction level is dropping
and dropping and dropping and dropping
and he might join your faction because
you've spent the last 50 turns playing a
very diplomatic game for example and not
really conquering any we're not really
starting any Wars or anything yeah and
so he might come and join you and
because he's great friends with that
general with that particular general
that powerful general the general might
actually go I went on going with my
friends and you might get you get might
gain that extra general as well because
of the power of that bond of friendship
those two characters so it's looking for
Connor ways to manipulate that and
looking for pitfalls as you say you know
if somebody really doesn't like you as a
faction leader then then you have to
find ways of raising their satisfaction
levels play playing to the kind of their
desires and their motivations
essentially what was the motivation on
creative Assembly's part to really focus
in on characters I mean there's always
characters in total war games but it
seems like that is the a huge theme
focus for this game absolutely
absolutely is I mean
in more recent games for Warhammer for
example we've had amazing characters on
a play because of the warhammer law in
the Warhammer universe but in terms of
having sort of multiple interlinked
relationships in the campaign game that
is the first time we've done that and it
feeds into battle as well so if you've
got two characters who are fierce
friends incredibly you know incredibly
close to that you know almost like
brothers and they go into battle
together and one of them falls in battle
and one of them dies in battle the other
one might go berserk you lose control of
him because all he'll want to do is
charge screaming towards the enemy and
take as many of them down as he can in a
blaze of glory right yeah so yeah it
plays into the battle and it's a battle
side of the game as well and I'm not
sure if you've seen it so far but
occasionally characters will you'll get
little conversations that spark between
characters in battle Wow see if you've
got rivals they'll they'll sort of
insult each other or you know you'll get
a bit of banter between friendly
characters a little insult between it
between enemies so so something really
cool so the feeling that you can build
up those relationships and see them play
out within the game and it kind of gives
you even more investment in oh for sure
yeah for sure I mean you know if you've
spent 100-200 turns you know kind of
with this character you know maybe
you've got one characters particular
favorite for you in your faction and you
seem getting unhappy about something
you're gonna do everything you can to
kind of cater to because you don't want
him to defect you don't want em to go
elsewhere you know and so it's keeping
an eye on that stuff and like you say
you just get a lot more investment in
the characters in this way because
they've got they've got much more much
more varied much more colorful
personalities than ever have before so
one of the things obvious you guys have
just come off the back of total war will
have a - what's it like kind of
returning back to a historical entry in
the series it's been great actually and
we've been we've been working with a guy
called Rafe de Crespigny who is he's
pretty much the foremost authority on
the Three Kingdoms period like
historically and diving back in and
kind of tackling a new well for us you
know a new period has been utterly
fascinating we've discovered loads
there's this there's so much about the
period that we have no idea about and
and so it's you know it's a it's a
really it's a really it's a real journey
of discovery to to go back to you know
historical games to this depth and this
scale again so yeah it's been great it's
gonna take especially in the West like
we typically don't learn about Chinese
history or Japanese history and so no
that's right right jumping in point for
people absolutely yeah yeah it's it's
been a real education for us and and
it's hard to understate the import of
hard to overstate story the importance
of the romance of the three kingdoms in
Chinese culture like I said it's it's
it's the subject of movies is the
subject of comics and books and cartoons
and all sorts of things these tolls have
been told and retold and retold since
the 14th century yeah and these
characters have taken on a life of their
own almost you know and you know these
these these are the stories he read in a
comic book when he's three years old you
know so I hope we're doing them justice
you know I realize sincerely hope we're
doing these guys justice and that you
know that we bring to life in an
authentic way yeah I was gonna say I
think lubbers just been knocked off his
horse yeah so we're at the final deal
this is our who done this is the guy
with the eye patch and the eyeball
eyeball suami
okay so what happens is when you can
engage in jewels and this is the way
we're supporting that whole kind of
character concepts as well and once
they're down on the ground they go this
is all wushu Martin motion-captured
wushu martial arts combat moves so
see how they really go for it Yelp's oh
yeah who didn't text down Tinubu here
but of course so this is this is this is
the point at which sow sow rides up and
there's a guy you'll notice to his right
and fans of ramus Three Kingdoms the
girl on the right will know his lube a
he was a really key figure in the period
and he's actually the guy that stood
behind sow sow got a new boo back in the
day lubu sat there and went you don't
want to execute me I can do I'm the most
platforms three kingdoms I can work for
you and South South yeah sound sounds
like a master strategist so South cells
going hmm actually I could use you and
Liu Bei goes once a betrayer always a
betrayer said that's where that's where
Liu Bei was finally finally sorted
basically so awesome well we were just
showing the screen when can people play
this sorry when can people expect a plan
so spring next year we haven't settled
on an exact date yeah a little way to go
yeah but yeah we've got obviously we've
just shown a glimpse of it here with the
battle but really we just wanted to show
how a vaca T of those environments are
what we're building and the depth of
detail and character in the units and
characters and things but there's so
much more to come with the campaign game
we've got tons of interesting new
features like the character stuff so
yeah we'll be rolling all that out over
the next few months and showing off a
lot more of the game awesome l thanks so
much for joining us on stage they agree
and have a good rest of the show yeah
you see if you're watching from home do
not go anywhere we are about to talk
about hitman 2 with people who made it
see you then
you